[Musik]
es ist sechs uhr morgens und die sonne
geht auf über dem hamburger hafen ruhe
und idylle liegt über der elbe aber der
eindruck täuscht das city never sleeps
der slogan den sich new york city zu
eigen gemacht hat der gilt auch für
hamburg den über 8.700 seeschiffe laufen
den hamburger hafen im jahr an und das
ganze rund um die uhr und damit ein
herzliches moin moin aus der freien und
hansestadt hamburg begleiten sie uns auf
eine 24 stunden reportage durch diesen
aufregenden ort wie nehmen sie mit auf
eines der größten containerschiffe im
hamburger hafen anlaufen begleiten die
arbeit derer die das schiff entgegen
nehmen die es entladen und die die
weiterverarbeitung der waren
organisieren aber bevor diese großen
containerschiffe hamburg überhaupt
anlaufen können da beginnt bereits die
arbeit und zwei die d11 lotsen die das
schiff an der elbmündung betreten und
lena hamann hat sie bei dieser
aufregenden arbeit begleitet
er soll einen lotsen zu einem frachter
auf der elbe vor brunsbüttel bringen der
ist auf dem weg von norwegen nach
hamburg
der lotse ist ja ortskundig das heißt
der weiß wo man lang fahren kann sieht
man sich das vorstellen als wenn sie
durch ein minenfeld gehen ohne führer
mullah durch den dschungel gehen oder
als wenn sie durch die selben team
fahren
fast keiner sicht
denn man kann ja nie sehen wo es genug
wasser die elbe ist ja sehr breit und
alles aber sie ist halt nicht überall ct
insgesamt drei dutzend boote sind hier
im einsatz egal bei welchem wetter
7000 mal im jahr bringen sie die 430 elb
und kanal nutzen zu den großen pötten
und lassen sie übersteigen während der
fahrt wenn wir neue fracht oder
kreuzfahrtschiffe können nicht langsamer
fahren als acht knoten um manövrierfähig
zu bleiben die alten lotsenboot schaffen
dieses tempo so gerade eben
für uns ist wichtig dass wir schneller
werden damit wir selber haben wenn ich
jetzt ganz ohne reserven mein manöver
fahren muss weil ich bei
höchstgeschwindigkeit die versetzung
durchführen muss
ja das erklärt dass ich fast von alleine
wenn ich kann er selber hat kann ich
auch in notsituationen also nach oben
hin nicht reagieren und das ist
natürlich auch wieder eine
gefahrenquelle
jetzt ist deshalb das neue lotsenboot im
einsatz gebaut in einer spezial werft in
schweden für fünfeinhalb millionen euro
die dithmarschen ist fast doppelt so
schnell wie ihre vorgänger 30 meter lang
und hier funktioniert alles elektronisch
kapitän christian gold kann von der
brücke aus alles überwachen tank stände
licht temperatur das ganze schiff
und ich kann das achterdeck sehen also
dass den hinteren teil des schiffes den
vorderen teil des schiffes
da sehen wir wie mein kollege unten
einer maschine ist und das ist auch sehr
wichtig wir fahren hier in einem gebiet
wo auch sehr viel länger sein kann und
wenn er unten in der maschine arbeiten
muss da kann es schon mal sein dass das
schiff sich so bewegt dass er zum
beispiel mit dem kopf dagegen schlägt
das werkzeug irgendwo hin fällt muss
nicht sein darf und dann kann man von
hier aus direkt reagieren
deshalb kam der schiffsmechaniker jetzt
auch während der fahrt arbeiten auf den
alten schiffen war das verboten und die
lotsen können sicherer übersteigen
selbst bei drei metern wellen das hier
ist ein bisschen größer wert von daher
berechenbar angenehm schwer und groß ist
gutes arbeiten bei sturm habe es noch
nicht ausprobiert den hatten das unglück
noch nicht
auch bei kälte ist es sicherer für die
crew die reling ist beheizt kann nicht
mehr überfrieren keine gefahr mehr
abzurutschen
im frühjahr wird das letzte alte
lotsenboot ausgemustert ersetzt durch
das schwesternschiff der dithmarschen
die steinburg und wenn die arbeit der
elf lotsen beendet ist dann beginnen sie
der hafenlotse und die sind letztendlich
dafür verantwortlich dass das schiff im
hamburger hafen auch festmachen kann so
nato school ist einer derjenigen die das
schon seit jahrzehnten machen die
schiffe werden immer größer immer
breiter wie steigt damit die
herausforderung was macht es dann so
schwierig wenn die schiffe größer werden
automatisch die frau war sein enger wir
kriegen keine weiteren boxen wir kriegen
keine breite fahrwasser hin
das einzige was wir ein bisschen
vergrößert haben in letzter zeit in die
drei kreise
die wurden angepasst an die neuen
schiffsgrößen aber was unsere große
herausforderung ist es einfach die masse
jetzt haben sie ja jeden tag mit
menschen aus unterschiedlichen nationen
zu touren sind die kapitäne eigentlich
alle gleich gut ausgebildet ist es
schwierig mit denen zusammenzuarbeiten
oder nehmen die die arbeit der lotse
schon sehr ernst die sind alle gleich
gut ausgebildet die haben einen
internationalen standard dass der scc
standort hat dem die ausgebildet sind
gerade reedereien die posco und china
shipping
die haben einen sehr hohen standard mit
den konkreten arbeiten hier sehr gut
zusammen
wir sehen den schiffen eigentlich immer
genau wo sie hin müssen weil das ist ja
es ist das sind der mehrere hundert
meter wurde er ist also wir werden
begleitet von offizieren auch die brutto
ohne den geht es ohne den würde ich das
nicht findet ja dann morgen mal sehen
wie es jetzt weitergehen denn jetzt geht
es an bord ist 340 meter langen
container riesen ching hongkong
keine leichte aufgabe denn der übergang
erfolgt während der fahrt stehen bleiben
ist ausgeschlossen
und er gerne auf ein neues schiff birgt
durchaus auch mal überraschungen
funktioniert die technik die das mit dem
kapitän sofort auf einer wellenlänge
sind immer neue herausforderungen sich
jedes mal spannend und der puls steigt
nicht nur wegen der neuen
herausforderung die treppen fordern
ihren tribut
ich dachte ich bin sportlich auf der
brücke übernimmt der lotse das kommando
in absprache mit dem chinesischen
kapitän hat mir kurz das schiff erklärt
nochmal alle wichtigen partie colas
erzählt brechen tiefgang maschine buch
strahl auf dem er traf nach hilfe die
brücken höhe sodass ich aktuellen
informationsstand habe ich habe ihnen
kurz darüber informiert was wir erwarten
diese schlepper wir nehmen welche seite
wir lange seite haben und wie viel ein
wie nach ausdrücken und in welcher
reihenfolge das machen so und jetzt
müssen wir gucken
der verkehr ist irgendwie so strömung
ist recht stark das sieht man schon wenn
man aus dem fenster guckt das müssen wir
sehen dass wir eben mit dem schiff die
fahrwasser mithalten dafür haben wir
terrestrische navigationshilfen die
haben das gerade wir sehen einmal unser
schiff wir sehen hier die landebahn die
hier vorne ist damit kontrolliere ich
also die die position im fahrwasser
gezählt was was heute besonders zu
beachten ist oder ist alles und die
herausforderung heute ist die starke
titel also er komplett der ersten kurz
hinter der ersten flut das ist
ungewöhnlich
wir haben also sehr viel strom zu
erwarten
ching hongkong aufgaben bringen wir das
fehler hätte gerne 12 schlepper fairplay
ich wollte die schlemmerfest haben hier
in köppern drogen da brauche ich sie
irgendwann zum steuern mit zum bremsen
außerdem ist im in einer kurvenfahrt das
schlepper festmachen sehr schwierig für
die schlepper das schwierige manöver in
der kurve ist geglückt die schlepper
haben die tonnenschwere last am sein
dass burka in sicht die hürden
gemeistert erleichterung bei der crew
war dann ein bisschen spannend und dann
muss man auch darauf hoffen dass die
informationen die vom kapitän komme halt
ich leute sind da das auch alles stimmt
und dass die schlepper dann auch noch
rechtzeitig versagen also ein bisschen
puls nach oben jetzt sind wir hier im
plan
er legt sehr gut auf dem ruder mit
steuerbord zehn komme ich hier ganz gut
um die kurve kann ein bisschen erhöhen
den redakteuren oder bremsen
das habe ich jetzt alles hier gut im
blick also von daher ist es jetzt ein
bisschen entspannung wieder angesagt
dass das ganze team arbeitet von vielen
handelnden personen ist das haben wir ja
schon auf der kommandobrücke erlebt aber
jetzt mein wendemanöver da haben die
schlepper kapitän ihren großen auftritt
unter dem kommando der hafenlotse
manövrieren sie das schiff an die
kaimauer in diesem fall am zeh
theatermittel eine aufregende arbeit der
schlepper kapitän jürgen hinrichs hat
sie dabei begleitet hallo bernd die
buchse fünf hört ja cosco alles klar
erstmal wollen wir fahren los rudi
herzog ist kapitän und fährt einen
hafenschlepper der bugsier reederei
ja wir haben jetzt drei antriebe ich
habe natürlich nur zwei hände und wir
sind nur rückwärts raus gefahren und ja
ich drehe jetzt mit den vorderen
antrieben das schiff auf kurs und dann
die reise los hier
zudem cosco england die boxee 5 ist ein
kraftpaket mit 6500 psn viertelstunde
ist hier in unserer position anderthalb
meilen auch schon hier zeigt uns der
kapitän noch wie wendig seine box 45 ist
also ich denke mal ich hab den besten
arbeitsplatz der welt also das macht
schon spaß
hamburg hat sein flair direkt vor airbus
in finkenwerder setzt sich dann der
schlepper vor die cosco england ein
gigant 366 meter lang mit 14.000
containern an bord der achter staat
schon fest gemacht
schwer ist es insofern dass er ziemlich
viel masse vor sich herschiebt und das
manöver insofern schwierig wird wir
müssen in den nahbereich des schiffes
reinfahren in der zeit muss ich
natürlich hoch konzentriert aufpassen
dass ich mich damit positioniere vor dem
schiff dass da nichts passiert dass wir
uns nicht über fährten praktisch wenn
die leine rauf geht dann muss ich den
schleppern natürlich so lange wie
möglich auf position halten weil die
denn allein erhält nicht viele aus wenn
der denn strom kommt dann reiste hab
dann müssen wir noch wieder von vorne
anfangen
für den containerhafen toller ort wird
der riese um 360 grad gedreht
[Musik]
volle pulle
der steuerbord halbe steuer war die 5
das nervöse lot sind
jürgen herzog hat das große
kapitänspatent und fährt seit sieben
jahren auf der bux 45
wir sind wir den cosco irgendwann fertig
einmal reinkommen das wasser für uns
eine woche haben schlepper kapitän
jürgen herzog und seine crew noch dienst
so lange bleiben die drei auf dem schiff
danach dürfen sie für zwei wochen an die
arbeit das löschen und dann wieder laden
des schiffes und das ganze
vollautomatisch wir befinden uns an
einem der modernsten container-terminal
der welt fast alles digital und per
computer kaum noch menschen im einsatz
die berufsgruppen werden immer
spezialisierter und hochtechnisierte wo
sie würden erklärt uns wie das ganze
funktioniert
von allen sieben weltmeeren kommen sie
nach hamburg in den größten seehafen
deutschlands seit über 800 jahren
schlägt hier das herz der stadt
[Musik]
aber der takkt hat sich verändert zeit
ist geld lange liegezeiten kann sich
keiner mehr leisten lastwagen ohne
fahrer trainer ohne kranführer der
container terminal altenwerder wirkt wie
ausgestorben
kein mensch nirgends eine welt aus eisen
und stahl beherrscht von maschinen und
rechnern und das rechnet sich denn
computer machen keine fehler übersehen
keinen container und brauchen keine
pause
der hightech hafen hat einiges an
romantik eingebüßt aber dafür ist die
arbeit hier körperlich viel leichter
geworden
früher war hafenarbeiter ein knochenjob
zehntausende von charlotte wurden per
barkasse zur arbeit über die elbe
gefahren
unter deck erwartete sie
schweißtreibende arbeit so eine
bananenstaude weg zwischen 30 und 50
kilo
diese unscheinbaren kisten
revolutionierten die hafenarbeiter 1967
kam das erste voll containerschiff in
hamburg an
mit gerade einmal 87 containern
[Musik]
heute sind solche riesen mit 4000
containern nichts ungewöhnliches
da gerade einmal 48 stunden sind alle
stark kisten von bord geräumt an der
hafenkante werden die container auf die
nächste station verladen
auch sogenannte lgs das steht für
automatik guided vehicles zu deutsch
automatisch gelenkten fahrzeuge
[Musik]
jedes sucht sich seinen eigenen weg sie
orientieren sich per funk im boden sind
16.000 transponder eingelassen
menschen dürfen das gelände nicht
betreten dann stoppt das gesamte system
die egs sind eine weiterentwicklung aus
dem hafen von rotterdam in rotterdam
fahren die fahrzeuge auf festen
leitlinien auf schleifen die im boden
versenkt sind und das macht es
erforderlich dass die fahrzeuge eben
sich eine bestimmte routen erhalten
unsere fahrzeuge können sehr flexibel
eingesetzt werden
die lgs fahren sogar selbstständig an
die zapfsäule wenn ihr bordcomputer im
tank meldet das nachfüllen übernimmt ein
roboter 1200 liter diesel passen in den
tank 48 stunden können die lgs damit
fahren und sie kommen sich dabei nie in
die quere miteinander und sie kann auch
aufeinander warten festgelegt wird das
alles durch die transportaufträge die
die fahrzeuge erhalten
da gibt es natürlich transportaufträge
unterschiedlicher priorität einen
transportauftrag der wichtiger es gibt
dem fahrzeug auf der fläche dann eine
art vorfahrt und die vorfahrt muss dann
von einem anderen fahrzeug entsprechend
gewährt werden
auch im container lager läuft alles
vollautomatisch in jedem lager block
fahren zwei stapel keine weil sie
unterschiedlich hoch sind können sie
völlig unabhängig voneinander arbeiten
das verdoppelt die umschlags leistung
statt 25 können ihr bis zu 50 container
pro stunde bewegt werden
und hier sitzen die choreografen des
maschinen ballett im leitstand des
terminals eine software organisiert das
ineinandergreifen der automatischen
arbeitsabläufe die menschen an den
bildschirmen kontrollieren nur noch ob
alles reibungslos vonstatten geht
erst ganz am ende der transportkette ist
wieder handarbeit gefragt wenn die
container auf lkw geladen werden steuern
menschen die greifer roboter während zu
gefährlich sie könnten fernfahrer
verletzten die versehentlich zu nahe an
ihrem lkw stehen nur menschen können mit
fehlern von menschen rechnen
es gibt also grenzen der automatisierung
sogar am container terminal altenwerder
ein vollautomatisches container-terminal
braucht natürlich hoch professionelles
personal zb diejenigen die die container
löschen da sind die container kranführer
gefragt die in einer immer höheren
geschwindigkeit dafür sorgen müssen dass
die schiffe entladen und dann
dementsprechend auch wieder beladen
werden
franziska reisen aber die erste kran
führen hier im hamburger hafen ist wenn
regen stellt und sie ihre arbeit vor und
wie wichtig auch die fahrrinnenanpassung
für ihren job
der arbeitsplatz von franziska reisender
liegt in 40 metern höhe
sie ist containerbrücken fahrerin und
belegt die dicken stahl kisten von den
schiffen an land und andersherum am
burchardkai direkt an der elbe ist
wirklich hier ankommt morgens die sonne
geht auf und man hat einen moment wo man
erst einmal so über das terminal gucken
kann und denkt hier arbeite ich mehr als
150000 menschen arbeiten direkt oder
indirekt im und für den hamburger hafen
von franziska reisen us arbeitgeber ist
die hamburger hafen logistik ag kurz
hallo
sie hat dort als bürokauffrau
eingefangen und dann gewechselt sie war
eine der ersten frauen überhaupt auf
einer containerbrücke die ersten frauen
einstellen und dann habe ich gedacht
warum von außerhalb wenn doch eigentlich
schon im betrieb ist die das gerne
machen möchte und hab mich dann intern
beworben
und das hat dann auch funktioniert doch
über die zukunft des hamburger hafens
entscheiden andere was wenn die
elbvertiefung nicht kommt die sogenannte
fahrrinnenanpassung unabdingbar für die
ganz großen containerschiffe und für
ihren arbeitgeber die hana ja es muss
sein es muss klappen dass die
fahrrinnenanpassung gemacht wird aber
was ist wenn nicht wie könnte das leben
bei der heirat dann aussehen und darüber
diskutiert man doch schon mal
eine antwort auf diese frage entscheidet
auch über hamburgs bedeutung für den
welthandel und über die perspektive von
franziska reisener eine weichenstellung
die von der politik angeschoben aber von
gerichten entschieden wird
eines aber bleibt klar es ist definitiv
der höchste arbeitsplatz im hamburger
hafen das gilt auch für brücken fahrer
dennis i 12 uhr schichtbeginn kriege sie
haben wir nicht nur einen sensationellen
ausblick sondern ohne frage auch einen
der spektakulärsten jobs die es hier im
hamburger hafen gibt warum haben sie
sich ausgerechnet dazu entschieden
container kranführer zu werden ja also
ich komme aus einer kleinen schiff hat
familie mein vater schon zu sie gefahren
war kapitän mein bruder ist schiffs
burker genau und deshalb ich habe viele
freunde die im hafen arbeiten und dann
habe ich quasi die initiative ergriffen
habe mich bei der haller beworben für
eine ausbildung zur fachkraft für
hafenlogistik und das hat geklappt ich
habe 2010 angefangen habe dann die
ausbildung abgeschlossen 2013
was fasziniert sie der hanse ja es ist
einfach hamburg der hafen und die auf
dem kranz verarbeitet und das ist die
herausforderung jetzt planen wir gerade
ein sehr großes containerschiff das ist
ja wie funktioniert das mit der
zusammenarbeit mit den kollegen die an
deck sind ja sehr gut
das problem hier gerade in der situation
wir arbeiten quasi hier und haben ein
container turm und da sehe ich nicht so
viel höher und wir verständigung und mit
einer sozusagen einer puppe hier rechts
ich habe ein weißer hand deckt der genau
weiß mich ein falls es hier irgendwelche
probleme gibt es wenn die steht er vorne
nach vor kannte der sieht ein bisschen
schief aus dass jetzt geht ja einmal rum
genau muss quasi einmal kurz auf die
andere seite gehen weit von der seite
steht wahrscheinlich hier in der 8
erkannte händen und kann leider nicht
durchkommen so was wie lange wollen wir
jetzt landseite weiter
woher wissen sie mal welche durch die
referenznummer und unten sitzt noch der
sowie die sogenannte brücken aufsicht
die sitzt quasi unten dort in dem
kleinen roten häuschen und der überwacht
das alles ein bisschen der hat auch den
stau plan und kam mir quasi schon den
container anzeigen mit dem man den tipp
quasi in dem er den tipp dann heißt das
erst verladen und dann sehe ich auch der
ist grün und dann weiß nicht welchen
container ich nehme nur zu genau das
macht das alles ein bisschen einfach auf
ein parallel dazu wird ihnen unten immer
der nächste bereitgestellt von den
wellen carrion korrekt genau die verdi
haben quasi auch ihre aufträge die holen
die container aus dem grab fanden
container unter die containerbrücken was
hat sich aus ihrer sicht in den letzten
jahren verändert der die termine werden
immer digitaler alles geht immer
schneller
der umschlag dem zu was ist da für sie
als kranführer die größte
herausforderung die schiffe werden auf
jeden fall mal größer das merkt man
schon die werden vor allem immer breiter
und wenn wir jetzt auf der wasserseite
laden quasi ganz rüber müssen merkt man
schon dass wir da an die grenzen kommt
das hätte jetzt tatsächlich etwas von
nadel ja genau man muss quasi hier schon
genau treffen alle vier twist loks
müssen quasi dort ins grün heißt ich bin
entriegelt sind können hochgenau ich
kann hoch kann mir den nächsten
container schnappen genau und dann habe
ich einmal die weiße lampe das bedeutet
auflage erst dann wenn ich quasi eine
auflage habt kann ich fair oder
entwickeln genau und rot heißt dann
fällige ganz herzen höher sehr gerne der
sekunde in der der container das schiff
verlässt oder wie man hier im hamburger
hafen sagt gelöscht wird geht es mit der
weiterverarbeitung weiter zum beispiel
dort hinten auf die bereitstehenden
güterzüge die die ware aus den
containern natürlich in ganz europa
weiter verteilen
seit 1866 hat der hamburger hafen einen
gleisanschluss union mentaler stellt uns
vor warum das für den hafen so wichtig
[Musik]
für die kommenden stunden sind sie die
herrin über 1000 ps lokführer olaf
ulbrich und rangier begleiter andreas
loebl sind heute das sächsisch
thüringische team auf der hybrid lockt
hamburg für den terminal betreiber
haller sind sie rundum dem burchardkai
unterwegs die eisenbahner hier sind das
rückgrat des hafens alles ist genau
koordiniert wir fahren jetzt eine zug da
ist eingefahren im bahnhof entgleist
vier davon jetzt ran nimmt der zug an
die lok mein kollege geht vor die spitze
des zuges und dann schieben wir denn ins
terminal zum botschafter seit 1866 hat
der hamburger hafen einen gleisanschluss
damals kam die wahre einzeln verpackt in
säcken und kisten
einst wurde stückgut von hafenarbeitern
und schauer leuten direkt von der
kaikante auf die züge geladen
ein stück hafen waren von vorgestern
gibt es auch heute noch hier zu sehen
der lastenkran von 1869 ist das älteste
stück des hafen museums und damit fast
genauso alt wie die hafenbahn selber
die logistik der gegenwart ist komplexer
geworden hamburg ist mittlerweile der
seehafen für länder wie österreich oder
italien
auch wenn seit der weltwirtschaftskrise
der containerumschlag schwächelt
konkurrenten wie rotterdam oder
antwerpen sind längst vorbei gezogen
doch was den abtransport ins hinterland
per eisenbahn anbelangt kann in europa
niemand mithalten mehr als 2,3 millionen
container wurden im vergangenen jahr
aufs gleis gesetzt jedes jahr zuckeln
rund 60.000 güterzüge über die 460
kilometer gleise quer durch den hafen
rund 130 eisenbahnunternehmen aus ganz
europa nutzen diese sonder strecken
das ende des zuges für lokführer olaf
ulbrich nicht zu sehen
rang ihr begleiter andreas loebl ist
sein auge und sei nur am funk es gilt
höchstgeschwindigkeit von 25 km/h die
container werden entweder
zwischengelagert oder gehen direkt das
schiff das weiß ich nicht
und dann werden neue könnte er auf den
auf den zukauf geladen die vom chef
kommen rangier begleiter andreas loebl
entkoppelt den 700 meter langen zug am
bahnhof am terminal burchardkai
spezielle brücken laden diese fracht nun
auf ein containerschiff nach übersee im
führerstand wartet bereits kollege olaf
ulbrich noch elf stunden müssen die
beiden weiter ordentlich rangieren denn
ohne die bahn wollte im hamburger hafen
so gut wie nichts
und auch wenn der hamburger hafen im
containerumschlag vielleicht ab und zu
mal schwächelt in der
hinterlandanbindung macht den hamburgern
so leicht niemand etwas vor ein größeres
problem für den hafen könnte aber werden
dass die container schiffe immer größer
werden ein schiff dieser kategorie ist
nicht mal mehr eines der größten bis zu
400 meter lang werden die ozeanriesen
und das erfordert eine gigantische
logistik aber wie weit ist die kapazität
der containerschiffe noch zu erweitern
sven regn berichtet ein schiff mit den
maßen eines flugzeugträgers wie und wann
de saint exupéry nutzt die nächtliche
windstille um nach hamburg zu surfen
der container riese ist für die elbe zu
schwer zu tief fast schon zu breit nur
auf dem höhepunkt der flut auf der
flutwelle kann es das schiff von der
nordsee in den hamburger hafen schaffen
am tage zeigt sich das nächste problem
bordwand und container bilden eine
gigantische segelfläche 20.000
quadratmeter rund doppelt so groß wie
ein fußballfeld starker wind so wie
heute würde das komplizierte
anlegemanöver riskant machen da einen
massa erstmal sich bewegt da muss man
genau wissen was man tut und wenn man
reagieren muss
deswegen ist es so dass wir sehr genau
unterscheiden zwischen den einzelnen
schiffsgrößen und das äußert sich dann
eben beispielsweise dahin gehen dass wir
für schiffe die 330 meter lang sind
andere ein laufbedingungen haben als für
schiffe die 360 meter sind und auch für
schiffe die den 400 meter lang sein
die anzahl der schlepper eine sperrung
der elbe sind dabei das eine
der wasserstand und die berühmte
handbreit wasser unter dem kiel das
andere
wie alle großen helfen überwacht auch in
hamburg eine nautische zentrale
permanent die tiefe der hafenbecken die
riesen der 400 meter klasse können schon
heute nur halb voll nach hamburg fahren
sonst heißt es grund kontakt nur
konsequent wäre es also das schiff
länger und breiter zu bauen damit es
besser aufschwimmt technisch ginge das
wir könnten das schiff noch um zwei
weitere reihen verbreitern wir könnten
es auch gut um 30 meter verlängern in
dieser konfiguration das heißt der
maschinenraum ist weiter etwas hinten
dass der kreis weitere vorne
denn dann landen wir so bei 28.000 cdu
danach müsste man sich überlegen wie man
das schiff doch signifikant anders
gestaltet struktur mäßig um die
festigkeit zu halten tatsächlich ist der
stahl das problem schiffe auf hoher see
biegen und strecken sich permanent
abhängig vom wellengang ab 480 meter
länge so die berechnung der schiffbauer
müsste der verbaute stahl dicker und
flexibler sein als es mit heutiger
technik machbar ist eine lösung ist
nicht in sicht
als auf den tag genau vor 50 jahren die
ms lancer hamburg an liefer größe kein
thema 1200 der damals völlig neuen
metallkisten konnte die länder aufnehmen
zu der zeit hielt man schiffe mit mehr
als 5.000 containern für reine illusion
heute das zeigt der größenvergleich
passt der zwerg 17 mal in die klasse der
20.000 der schiffe der größte
planungsstand ist 23.000 ist auch schon
gezeichnet also die schiffe werden
gebaut starttermin wird nächstes jahr
sein ist etwas breiter ist jetzt statt
den 59 61 meter breit und kommt dann auf
23.000 container und der nächste schritt
wäre dann wirklich die verlängerung auf
über 400 meter dann werden würden wir
430 meter und 61 meter breite sehen um
wären dann so bei 24 25.000 für hamburg
als hafen im binnenland stellen sich
dabei probleme die die konkurrenten aus
antwerpen und rotterdam nicht haben die
fahren muss breiter und tiefer werden
hafen und stadt kämpfen vor dem
bundesverwaltungsgericht gegen auflagen
und verbote eine seltene pflanze namens
schierlings wasser fenchel würde der
elbvertiefung weichen müssen dagegen
klagen umweltschützer
eines aber ist klar hamburg muss
nachziehen
sonst zieht die konkurrenz vorbei wir
dürfen nur eins nicht verkennen nur mit
der fahrrinnenanpassung allein ist es
nicht getan sondern die infrastruktur
die nachgelagerte infrastruktur der bahn
der straßen ins deutsche hinterland ist
eine sache die wir im auge behalten
müssen denn antwerpen und rotterdam
haben
im letzten jahr enorme zuwächse
verzeichnen können hamburg hat stagniert
zum glück für hamburg enden die
zukunftsvisionen der schiffbauer derzeit
bei größen die 28.000 container
aufnehmen können
flüssiggas und elektroantrieb
eigenständiges be und entladen und
autonomes fahren das sind die
schiffsmodelle für die kommenden 20
jahre
die containerschiffe der zukunft sind
damit schneller und flexibler und
vermutlich dann sogar auch wieder etwas
kleiner als heute die in hongkong die
wir vorhin begleitet haben als sie an
der kaimauer festgemacht hat ist mit 336
metern fast schon ein relativ kleines
schiff wie gesagt bis zu 400 meter sind
inzwischen an der tagesordnung im
hamburger hafen und das stellt den hafen
vor große probleme
andreas buchmann stellvertretender
hafenkapitän was heißt das für den
hamburger hafen wenn die kapazitäten der
schiffe immer größer werden kann der
hafen da noch mithalten
also wir haben da zwei herausforderungen
das eine sind die herausforderung die
wir haben als schiffsarzt polizeibehörde
wir sind gesetzlich verpflichtet sichere
verkehrswege vorzuhalten
das heißt wir müssen gucken bei den
immer größer werdenden schiffe im
bereich die verkehrsfläche aus um diese
schiffe sicher zu manövrieren
das ist unser part und die betriebe
müssen sich privat darauf einstellen
dass sie ihre anlagen entsprechen für
diese immer größer breiter und vor allen
dingen auch höher werdenden schiffe
vorbereiten für die reeder ist
entscheidend dass die liegezeiten kurz
bleiben für die für die container
terminal natürlich die umschlagszahlen
relevant das heißt die geschwindigkeit
erhöht sich auch immer mehr
haben sie das gefühl dass der in der
grenze gesetzt ist dass irgendwann mal
sagen wir mal das maximum erreicht ist
was möglich ist also von der
schiffsgrößen entwicklung sind wir offen
wir warten ab was der markt um sagt und
reagieren darauf indem wir bei
entsprechenden nachfragen von reedereien
entsprechende simulations- läufe hier im
markt für den hamburger hafen machen
würden und die erkenntnisse daraus
würden wir dann verwenden um die frage
zu beantworten können wir diese schiffe
noch abfertigen und wenn ja welche
finanziellen mittel müssen wir dafür
aufwenden und die andere frage ist
schlicht und einfach bei den immer
größer werdenden schiffe ob die ladung
die damit verbunden ist überhaupt noch
rechtzeitig auf den termin als
abgefedert werden kann
das ist eine große logistische
herausforderung während es früher zwei
oder dreitausend container gewesen sind
die pünktlich vor ort sein mussten sind
wir heute bei 10.000 containern die für
den export und für den import vernünftig
abgefertigt werden müssen
und ich glaube da kommen wir langsam in
grenzbereichen und wenn wir die
fahrrinnenanpassung hoffentlich
demnächst haben werden dann bedeutet das
dass die schiffe nicht unbedingt größer
werden aber durch die
fahrrinnenanpassung haben wir bessere
möglichkeiten die schiffe aneinander
vorbei zu bekommen das heißt die
derzeitige breiten regulierung wird sich
entspannen und die gleichen schiffe die
wir heute haben können unter
wirtschaftlich besseren bedingungen den
hafen anlaufen und wieder verlassen weil
wir im schnitt dann einen meter tiefgang
mehr haben für die gleichen schiffe das
hat sich über die jahre verändert ist
die schlagzeile auch immer höher und
wenn man schneller geworden also auch
die herausforderung für die häfen
wir können das anhand von statistiken
nachweisen dass sich zwar die gesamtzahl
der umgeschlagenen container nicht
wesentlich erhöht aber die schiffsgrößen
immer größer werden wir hoffen aber dass
wir im augenblick da so ein gleichklang
haben und dass sich die entwicklung für
uns etwas stoppt so lange bis wir die
fahrrinnenanpassung haben
und dann mit diesen schiffen wieder
besser umgehen können danke andreas
brummermann ja 28 stunden wird die ching
hongkong hier im hamburger hafen liegen
das ist eine immer kürzer werdende
liegezeit wir haben es gehört die räder
haben natürlich ein großes interesse
daran diese zeit zu minimieren das ist
die einzige chance für die besatzung das
schiff zu verlassen und in hamburg hat
es tradition dass aus allen herren
länder die es seeleute dann ins
seemannsheim duckten gehen und dort von
sozialarbeitern betreut werden die
übrigens auch aus aller herren länder
kommen
okay ich bin aber ich bin glücklich
hamburg bedenken habe einer her
deutsch lernt wie sie ihn hier rufen
seit einigen monaten abram so sein
vollständiger name ist für ein jahr als
freiwillige beim simons club bleiben
mitten im hafen der 26 jährige hilft
seeleuten aus der ganzen welt die hier
einkaufen oder sich einfach entspannen
er war sich am meisten mag ist es mit
den seeleuten zu reden
sie sind wirklich lustige nette leute
wenn sie hierher in den club kommen sind
wir für sie wie ein teil der familien
erste land war das verfahren lief adams
seine familie lebt fast 40 flugstunden
entfernt von hamburg aus gesehen am
anderen ende der welt kiribati ein
inselstaat in der südsee der gerade mal
etwas mehr als 100.000 einwohner hat
wenn ich die leute fragen mich woher
kommst du und dann sag ich aus kiribati
und dann fragen sie mich woher genau aus
afrika das ist nicht afrika sage ich es
ist eine pazifische insel
sein erster eindruck von deutschland im
winter war ein schock als ich die bäume
blätter sein und ich dachte dieses
deutschland kein grün
sie sagen wir es ist winter alle blätter
sind abgefallen und kommen erst im
sommer wieder okay sagte ich es sieht
furchtbar aus
in seiner heimat arbeitet als
sozialarbeiter er ist teilnehmer eines
stipendienprogramms der nordkirche für
junge menschen die aus
entwicklungsländern stammt bei einer
gastfamilie bergedorf lebt er hier im
doktor alben trifft er gelegentlich auch
landsleute
denn für die reederei hamburg süd
arbeiten viele seeleute aus kiribati um
die wussten schon bevor wir wussten dass
er sozusagen kommt zu uns kommt über
dieses programm das er in den druck
und da haben wir erlebt dass die inhalte
die klimatischen seeleute ganz ganz
stolz sind dass ein landsmann hierher
kommt hier hilft hier bei der arbeit
dabei ist sein lieblingsplatz in der
stadt ist neben der elbphilharmonie app
kommt hierher wenn er heimweh hat ich
mag das wasser und den weg es fühlt sich
anders zu hause generell es ist ein
großartiges erlebnis hierzu seien noch
sechs monate bleibt in hamburg zurück in
seiner heimat will er in einem
trainingscenter für seeleute arbeiten
und dort seine erfahrung an andere
weitergeben
seit über 30 jahren kümmert sich der
doktor um die seeleute aus aller welt
und ich habe gelernt dass man sich hier
duzt anke wir als diakonin wie hat sich
das verändert die zeiten im hafen für
die seeleute werden immer kürzer
kommt trotzdem noch welche oder haben
die gar keine chance mehr
doch sie nehmen sich die chance ist ganz
viele sparen sich diese zeit sozusagen
den anderen häfen auf hier kommt daher
hier kann der vater freies wlan hier
kann er umsonst telefonieren nach hause
egal ob nach klingers oder ins letzte
dorf von indien hier kann eine
geldüberweisung machen hier kriegt ein
offenes ohr
die kriegt ja ein lächeln der
ehrenamtlichen mitarbeiter die hinter
dem tresen stehen wie wir der kostenlos
von bord mit dem erdgas bus abgeholt und
hier fühlt er sich zuhause und weil er
sich zu hause fühlt bringt er was mit
alles was man hier sieht ist nicht weil
wir ein schifffahrtsmuseum sind sondern
weil die seeleute von zu hause was
mitbringen einschließlich einer
chinesischen gottheit die wir oben im
raum der stille haben einfach weil sie
sich wohlfühlen es ist mir zu hause und
hier leben sie auf mit welchen sorgen
kommen die zu ihnen ist das sehr
unterschiedlich oder hat dass so eine
tendenz die probleme ansehen nehmen zu
oder aufsehen nehmen zu globalisierung
macht dinge schwieriger das eben dinge
aber es ist natürlich auch der taifun
auf den philippinen es ist natürlich die
piraterie vor somalia die angst
mitschwingt es ist der kapitän er sagt
anke ich will nie wieder über kinder
rucksäcke fahren im mittelmeer nach was
wenn man über monate sozusagen an bord
eingesperrt ist
und das problem hat dass man sich nicht
mehr unterhalten kann weil der andere
kann die platte von zu hause schon
rückwärts bieten was will man auch
erzielen ich erlebe ganz oft in meinen
telefonzellen dass der seemann und ich
kenne es von meinen beiden eigenen
seeleuten ich bin meinem verheiratet und
meine große tochter ebenfalls zu sie
wird die haben nichts mehr zu erzählen
was sollen sie dann auch erzählen zum
fünften mal dass sie den kolben gezogen
haben oder dass sie weiß der himmel was
gemacht haben ich höre mir das auch
immer an war denker der oft an meine
familie
die leute zu hause ja denn neulich
seeleute zu heiligen abend kurz vorher
da kam der erste rein und sagen du
schickst doch geld auf die viele dinge
sei jetzt das mache ich guck mal hier
sind 50 euro dann kann meine frau machen
geschenk kaufen ich sag das mal wieder
ich habe mir nie ist die reine stand
drei hintereinander beim evd büro jetzt
weiter geht mir 100 dollar
ich sage nach zwei habe ich mir auch
eben überlegt als der kollege das
gemacht hat das so eine gute idee
der dritte kommt rein und gibt nur 150
dollar ich sehe jetzt von ihm beraten
das sind einmal drei kindern das vierte
unterwegs das ist das was sie natürlich
erzählen mir erzielen ihre bilder zeigen
von zu hause ihren hund zeigen
ich habe viele jahre gab zum druck da
eben auch ein diensthund es gibt der
dienst katze jetzt kommt ein neuer
dienst und ich weiß diese leute werden
begeistert sein dass es menschliches ich
danke ihnen
und während sich die seeleute in den
dickdarm eine kleine ruhepause gönnen
können geht der betrieb im hamburger
hafen und rund um ihr schiff natürlich
weiter container werden entladen und
schiffe wieder beladen und sobald die
container an land sind beginnt auch die
arbeit für die sicherheitsbehörden
hamburger hafen für die
wasserschutzpolizei oder den zoll
denn nicht alle container enthalten
waren die da auch wirklich rein gehört
ist noch nicht so lange her da gelang
den zollfahndern ein spektakulärer fund
über 700 kilo kokain sven regn war für
uns dabei
diese pakete sind teil eines wahren
krimis und das rauschgift war auf dem
weg in die niederlande 7 117 kilogramm
reines kokain versteckt in einem mit
schrott beladenen container marktwert
mindestens 140 millionen euro
kein wunder dass die kriminellen
hintermänner schon danach suchten
bewaffnete täter haben zwei personen im
umfeld der logistikfirma als geiseln
genommen
die in einen transportwagen eingesperrt
einem dieser beiden geiseln ist die
flucht gelungen er hat die polizei
verständigt und die polizei konnte die
geiselnahme unblutig beenden das heißt
die geiselnehmer wurden festgenommen
in solchen blei ummantelten paketen war
das rauschgift eingepackt die ladung kam
aus südamerika anscheinend eine
schmuggelroute die die täter häufiger
nutzen eine kriminelle organisation eine
tätergruppierung die äußerst
gewaltbereit und aggressiv vorgeht und
jetzt ihre ware sucht und bei diesem
vorgehen auch nicht vor geiselnahmen
oder auch sogar vom mord nicht
zurückschreckt in einem der hamburger
container terminals beginnt die suche
nach dem kokain auf einem schiff aus
südamerika liegt der container den die
niederländischen ermittlungsbehörden
bereits ausfindig gemacht hatten zöllner
wie rainer langholz gehen zusätzlich an
bord und überprüfen das schiff es könnte
ja durchaus sein dass die schmuggler
komplizen an bord haben
[Musik]
das eine ist es her sag ich mal hier vor
uns zu verbergen
auf der anderen seite muss ich natürlich
dann auch noch auf dem markt liegen
spricht also erstmal von bohr- und
natürlich dann auch hier an den
richtigen mann bringen das muss man
natürlich auch noch wieder nur leider
auch nicht rainer langholz schätzt dass
so ein port gut 50.000 mögliche
verstecke bietet auf der brücke hat zwar
nicht jeder aus der mannschaft zu tritt
aber gerade das könnte eine einladung
für die schmuggler seien
das sollte man die frage ob oder
inwieweit die personen ist hier
versteckt hat auch rein kommt und man
kann es natürlich sein dass jetzt meine
treiben hier wo ich jetzt gucken einer
sks notdürftig versucht hat zu
verstecken oder angst hat dass das
vorgefunden wird oder dass rausgenommen
hat und wir uns hoffentlich dann noch
rausfinden die nadel im heuhaufen ist
wohl einfacher zu finden
die kontrollen sollen aber auch
abschrecken das wahre schmuggel
potenzial das wissen auch rheinland holz
und seine kollegen steckt in den
container wie der heute vorgestellte
rekord pokal und einer langholz und die
kollegen waren für die sicherheit des
rauschgiftes verantwortlich schließlich
sind die beiden paletten zusammen mehr
als 140 millionen euro wert bei
vorsichtiger schätzung
was ist der größte jemals vom zoll in
deutschland sichergestellte kokain
aufgriff das muss man sagen wir haben in
dieser container prüfanlage die wir seit
1996 betreiben bislang rund 5,3 tonnen
kokain sicherstellen können haben jetzt
die sechs tonnen grenze geknackt daneben
haben wir ganz viel heroin warten und so
weiter durch die anlage sicher stellen
können
in der container prüfanlage des
hamburger hafens haben die zöllner das
kokain gefunden
die röntgenanlage durchleuchtet einen
lkw samt ladung innerhalb von einer
minute bei der bildauswertung erkennen
die beamten jeden trick container mit
schrott sind immer verdächtig deswegen
hat man das so drapiert im container
auch die wand von sich dass hier immer
so ein bisschen das macht die gegenseite
auch ganz gern das werden die container
tür aufgeht das haben gleich was
hingegen kommt dass man gleich
abgeschreckt ist als zöllner und dann
sieht man hier unter diesen ganzen
schrott sieht man hier die pakete mit
kokain das ist jetzt die seitenansicht
des containers des lkws hier in der
draufsicht sieht man es dann natürlich
noch ein bisschen deutlicher die
einzelnen pakete
was dann folgt ist ein ermittler kniff
wie aus dem film die beamten tauschen
die schmuggelware möglichst schnell und
unauffällig gegen einen gleich schweren
ersatz der container setzt danach seine
reise äußerlich unverändert fort
wir haben auch die mittel in einer
kontrollierten weiter lieferung so heißt
es bei uns das heißt also wir nehmen den
den das kokain raus tun andere sachen da
rein verwanzen den container und
letztendlich auch so wie wir das dann in
dem konkreten fall heute wäre das aber
zu gefährlich gewesen die zollfahnder
wollten möglichst schnell mit ihrem fund
an die öffentlichkeit gehen wird soll
hofft dass die eigentlichen empfänger in
den niederlanden dadurch ihre
gewalttätige suche nach der wahren
beenden auf das konto der
rauschgifthändler geht nach bisherigen
ermittlungen bereits ein ermordeter
lagerarbeiter es war zu befürchten dass
diese geiselnahme nicht die einzige
gewalttat in holland bleibt dass die
täter weiter auf der suche nach ihrem
stoff an personen rangehen personen
bedrohung personen gefährden an leib und
leben und um das zu verhindern haben
sind wir jetzt raus mit den holländern
und habe mitgeteilt die ware liegt bei
uns der deutsche zoll hat die 7 117 kilo
sichergestellt um den druck aus dem
kessel zu nehmen und um die
tätergruppierung soweit zu beruhigen
dass die lücke nicht bei ihnen in der
organisation zu suchen ist
normalerweise nehmen sich die
zollfahnder mindestens sechs wochen zeit
um die hintermänner zu ermitteln in
diesem fall aber gegen die sicherheit
auch der transport mitarbeiter vor
hinter der postkarten kulisse des
hamburger hafens spielen sich eben auch
gefährliche schmuggel krimis ab
über 700 kilo koks das ist wirklich eine
ganze menge
preis ein nachbar dienststellenleiter
bei der wasserschutzpolizei der schlägt
daraus dass polizisten herzen bisschen
höher oder bei einem derartigen von
natürlich so ein erfolg den die
zollfahnder da langt haben das schlägt
auch das politische herz höher
denn letzten endes ziehen alle an einem
strang ob soldo polizei wir wollen die
sicherheit gewährleisten gerade auch im
hamburger hafen eine internationale
drehscheibe und da sind wir gratulieren
wir den kollegen sehr herzlich das ist
über die jahre anders geworden was hat
sich verändert klar verbrechen wird
immer raffinierter
sie legen aber ja auch nach was hat sich
das hat sich im aufgabenbereich getan
der hamburger hafen hat sich sehr
verändert seit den 70er jahren ende der
sechziger jahren hat sich die transporte
geändert
wir haben viele hunderte tausende
container es gibt kaum noch stückgut
demzufolge hat sich auch die delikte
verändert wie la barre möglicherweise
geschmuggelt wird die ware nicht richtig
transportiert wird wie andere delikte
entstehen diebstähle ist das modus
operandi hat sich geändert und darauf
müssen wir uns natürlich ein stellen
haben wir uns eingestellt die
sicherheitslage im hamburger hafen hat
sich seit den terroranschlägen in new
york verändert oktober haben wir
bei uns strukturell eingerichtet und das
sind unsere hauptaufgaben und das ist
das was ich auch am meisten verändert
aber die alltägliche arbeit wie kann man
die beschreiben das ist ja so vielfältig
im hamburger hafen von ganz regulären
kontrollen also beispielsweise schiffe
oder sonstige ist aber sie haben ja auch
teile die zu ihnen gehören die gar nicht
im wasser sind sondern richtig wie
wasserschutzpolizei ist erstmal im
gesamten hamburger hafen zuständig und
deren randgebiete zu den randgebieten
gehören aber auch ganz normale
wohnviertel
da sind wir die ganz normale polizei
auch im hamburger hafen sind wir die
ganz normale schutzpolizei mit schutz
polizeilichen aufgaben das geht von
verbrechensbekämpfung im ersten angriff
bis zur aufnahme von verkehrsunfällen
und den überwachung des verkehrs das
alles machen wir zusätzlich zu den
weiteren aufgaben die wir haben als der
einmal wären die grenzpolizeilichen
aufgaben hamburger hafen
wir sind die grenzpolizei jedes
seeschiff wird eingehen und ausgehend
grenzpolizeiliche abgefertigt das machen
wir in vertretungen sozusagen für den
bund wir sind genauso zuständig für
alles was mit gefahrgut zu tun haben
alle gefahrgut containertransport
transporte auf dem auf dem lkw auf der
bahn landeseigenen bahn entgegen unserer
zuständigkeit und diese kontrollieren
wir ein thema was man nicht sofort mit
der wasserschutzpolizei verbindet ist
der hochwasserschutz
das sind da ihre aufgaben die
wasserschutzpolizei hat die aufgabe im
hochwasserschutz in katastrophen bezug
zu stellen das sind punkte die ihr bei
hochwasser sturmfluten überschwemmte
gebiete fahren um menschenleben zu
retten und um sachen von hohem wert zu
retten
das mögen wir auch in den sturm
flugsaison drei bis vier mal mit unseren
wasserschutz polizeilichen kräften
insgesamt 500 in hamburg und dort lernen
wir und trainieren die fähigkeiten
notwendig sind sowie schwierige
situationen zu meistern
hochwasserschutz nicht nur ein thema für
die wasserschutzpolizei das ist klar
viele behörden in hamburg sind davon
betroffen denn obwohl hamburg so weit im
landesinneren liegt das hochwasser immer
ein thema und juri kösters hat sich mit
dem hochwasserschutz in hamburg
hamburg rüstet sich will vorbereitet
sein auf sturmfluten oder
überschwemmungen
aber auch auf den weltweiten anstieg des
meeresspiegels am hafen wird aktuell die
hauptlinie auf über 8 meter ausgebaut
bei der bisher höchsten flut stieg das
wasser auf 645 zwei meter unter der
aktuellen schutz höher
doch das könnte in ein paar jahrzehnten
zu niedrig seien
ein grund die entwicklung des 11 der
tägliche unterschied zwischen
niedrigsten und höchsten wasserstand bei
ebbe und flut
heute liegt der tägliche pegel
unterschied bei über 3,5 meter damit
läuft aktuell so viel wasser nach
hamburg wie nie zuvor in der geschichte
ungünstig wurde im hintergrund des
klimawandels
denn vorsichtig geschätzt steigt der
meeresspiegel bis ende des jahrhunderts
um einen halben meter
andere schätzungen gehen sogar von mir
aus so der aktuelle bericht des
weltklimarats im drastischsten szenario
geht er von einem anstieg von bis zu
einem meter aus ein noch deutlich
höherer anstieg des meeresspiegels also
weit über einen meter können nur durch
das abschmelzen der eisschilde
verursacht werden so der weltklimarat ob
wann und in welchem ausmaß das passieren
wird ist für die forscher schwer
vorherzusagen
zum konzept des artenschutzes hört neben
dem hochwasserschutz natürlich auch das
was an sicherheitskräften sonst noch im
hamburger hafen vor ort ist das ist zum
einen die wasserschutzpolizei und zum
anderen natürlich die feuerwehr auf
diesen 30 jahre alten feuerlöschboot
oberschützenmeister ressort ist häufig
ruhe aber manchmal eben auch großeinsatz
so zum beispiel im jahre 2016 als es
wahnsinnig schwierig war einen brand auf
einem containerschiff zu löschen das
ging über stunden lara stratmann war für
uns dabei
es ist ein marathon einsatz wie ihn die
feuerwehr selten erlebt die ganze nacht
kämpfen 300 kräfte gegen die flammen
glühend heiß ist es im inneren des
laderaums der brandherd nahezu
unerreichbar 20 meter unter deck und
dort ist es rund 180 grad heiß
entscheidend das feuer darf nicht auf
die anderen container übergehen um
unterbrochen wird die bordwand gekühlt
um ein auseinanderbrechen des schiffs zu
vermeiden
in der nacht leitet die feuerwehr
kohlendioxid in den laderaum eigentlich
eine bewährte maßnahme um das feuer zu
ersticken
doch das gelingt nicht die temperatur im
laderaum steigt am morgen wieder und die
feuerwehr entscheidet der laderaum muss
geflutet werden
40.000 liter wasser pro minute pumpen
die feuerwehrleute in den rumpf jetzt
kommt es darauf an das schiff genau zu
beobachten denn wegen der wassermengen
könnte der container riese kippen
techniker messen deshalb ununterbrochen
die trennung des schiffs spezialkräfte
aus dem ganzen norden hat die feuerwehr
herbeigerufen
sie sollen jetzt den laderaum öffnen
abseits der dramatik auf dem schiff
kommt es auf der a 7 zu mehreren beinahe
unfällen weil autofahrer plötzlich das
tempo drosseln oder sogar anhalten
die wasserschutzpolizei hatte eine
sonderkommission eingerichtet die die
ermittlungen führen soll
ausgebrochen war das feuer vermutlich
bei schweißarbeiten ein großeinsatz er
glücklicherweise nur sehr selten im
hamburger hafen vor kommt trotzdem
die feuerwehr muss bereit sein
brandoberinspektor thorsten wissen wie
halten sie ihre männer und frauen bei
der stange dass die immer für so etwas
vorbereitet und das kann ja jederzeit
passgenau alltägliches training ist ganz
immens wichtig für unsere einsatzkräfte
sie alle szenarien die wir uns so
ausgedacht haben bzw die uns hier im
alltag drohen können werden wir auch
immer wieder durchspielen wie wir es im
hintergrund auch sehen brandbekämpfung
auf see oder auf der elbe
menschenrettung logischerweise damit
verbunden wird im zusammenspiel zwischen
den sicherheitskräften alltäglich geübt
einzeltraining mit lösch boten oder
kleinbooten gehört genauso dazu wie die
brandbekämpfung mit einem ganzen
löschteam also ein löschzug der auf das
löschboot übersteigt und dann die
brandbekämpfung auf dem wasser übt und
trainiert inklusive der menschenrettung
das sehen wir auch gerade hier im
hintergrund was genau simulieren sie
jetzt jetzt gibt es ein polizei
hubschrauber der die lage auf diesen
brennenden schulen verbannt erkundet und
dann die einsatzkräfte instruiert wenn
menschen zu retten sind wird es auch
vorkommen dass rettungskräfte aus dem
hubschrauber zu diesen personen ins
wasser springen die rettung vorbereiten
wir sehen positionslichter auf der elbe
von betroffenen
parallel dazu wie gesagt werden
informationen für die heilungskräfte
überspielen wo der brandherd auf dieser
schule ist und wie die löschmaßnahmen am
besten zu koordinieren sind
funktioniert das zusammenspiel der
unterschiedlichen einsatzkräfte wie es
hier simuliert wird gut ist das ein sehr
eingespieltes system das funktioniert
sehr gut dadurch das wissen häufig
trainieren und jedes zahnrad im
extremfall dann auch ineinander greift
mit dem anderen so dass wir optimale
bedingungen vorfinden für die zu
rettende person und auch den schadensort
so dass wir den schaden versuchen zu
minimieren und die menschen
schnellstmöglich zu retten
jetzt ist das ja eine simulation die
tatsächlich glücklicherweise nicht jeden
tag vorkommt
was sind die alltäglichen dinge um es
mal so vorsichtig zu formulieren
die im hafen passieren was sind ihre
einsätze das gros der einsätze begrenzt
sich auf die menschen oder
personenrettung aus dem wasser aus dem
elbwasser wo ein und durch einen
unglücksfall eine person im wasser not
geraten ist und wir dann so vor dem
ertrinken retten wollen dadurch benutzen
oder hierfür benutzen wir dann auch die
kleinboote weil die deutlich wendiger
sind als die großen löschboote
wenngleich für diese auch einsetzen das
ist dann der klassische 112 einsatz mann
über bord oder mann über bord würde man
das auf hoher see nennen hier im hafen
würden wir dann sagen person im wasser
ist ja wichtig und general ist der
person im wasser oder menschenrettung
aus dem wasser wo wir dann im
zusammenspiel mit der deutschen lebens
rettungs gesellschaft und der
wasserschutzpolizei und wie gesagt
diesen kleinen boden dann tätig werden
um schnellstmöglich diese person aus dem
wasser zu holen weil unter schwierigen
witterungsbedingungen ist die
überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit sehr gering
das heißt wir müssen schnell vor ort
sein und dann auch tätig werden um
effektiv hilfe zu leisten ich sage
herzlichen dank und den beginn unseres
berichts über die feuerwehr damit
begonnen mit einem großbrand der auf
einem terminal hier im hamburger hafen
stattgefunden hat und nicht nur die
terminals sind das tragende bild des
hamburger hafen sondern auch die werften
und da in erster linie die absolute gros
werft blohm & voss eine wechselvolle
geschichte über 100 jahre alt und seit
einem jahr im besitz der lürssen werft
peter kleffmann herzlich angesehen wie
das funktioniert und natürlich noch ein
blick zurück gewagt in der geschichte
von blohm & voss
zehn millionen euro hat lösen auf der
werft investiert einer war schon einmal
chef hier bis er vor zehn jahren ging
wohl auch aus frust vor dem stillstand
klaus bock schulte dann kam er wieder
als vertreter des neuen eigentümers
lösen
als ich nach ziemlich genau zehn jahren
das erste mal die werft im november 2016
wieder von innen gesehen habe war ich
wirklich enttäuscht und entsetzt über
das was alles nicht passiert ist das
muss man wirklich so sagen
von daher hat blohm & voss über viele
jahre einfach nicht die aufmerksamkeit
und nicht die investitionen bekommen die
es gebraucht hätte um in den märkten
wettbewerbsfähig zu sein der staat 1877
auf steinwerder war holprig hermann
blohm und ernst voss fehlten die
aufträge die ersten schiffe baute die
werft auf eigene kosten erst jahre
später wurde sie groß vor allem aufträge
der kaiserlichen marine sicherten den
mehr als 1200 arbeitern dem job bei den
handels marinen waren sie seit anfang
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts berühmt die
sogenannten flying p liner der hamburger
reederei die viermastbark waren die
schnellsten und zuverlässigsten
frachtsegler der welt damals arbeiteten
bis zu 13.000 menschen bei blohm & voss
in den 20er jahren waren es die
schnellsten passagierdampfer die blohm &
voss berühmt machten
dennoch kostete die weltwirtschaftskrise
10.000 werftarbeitern den job nahrung
für hitlers ideologie in der nazizeit
wurde blohm & voss zur effizienten
kriegsmaschine das größte schlachtschiff
der welt die meisten u boote kamen aus
hamburg mit gebaut durch hunderte kz
häftlinge
die werft war ein hauptziel der
alliierten bomber nachkriegs eine der
neustart mit 200 beschäftigten
mit erfolg ende der 50er jahre laufen
frachter küstenmotorschiff und später
container schiffe vom stapel die helden
und dogs sind voll belegt trotz der
schon damals aufkommenden konkurrenz in
asien geht es blumen und frost gut
stapellauf der tokyo express 1972 mit
knapp 300 m damals das größte
containerschiff der welt
[Musik]
das traditionsunternehmen profitierte
auch vom wettrüsten der supermächte
fregatten und zerstörer ja sogar
panzerteile verließen die hallen an der
elbe und verhinderten wirtschaftlich
schlimmeres zum 100 jährigen
firmenjubiläum schmiedete bundeskanzler
helmut schmidt einen werften aktionsplan
dennoch forderte die werftenkrise viele
opfer die hdw gleich nebenan bereits
einen werftenverbund gerät in schieflage
trotz werks besetzung und streiks
mussten schließen
1986 übernimmt blohm & voss den
konkurrenten ein jahr später ist das
werk dennoch geschichte nicht allen geht
es schlecht und fonds erwirbt sich mit
superyachten anfang der 90er jahre einen
exzellenten ruf
allerdings war dies 2009 ausgeliefert
eclipse des russischen milliardärs
abramowitsch die letzte sensation auf
steinwerder dafür begann in den 90ern
eine illustere eigentümer parade
der mutterkonzern thyssenkrupp spaltete
das unternehmen auf weitere
ausgliederungen folgten pfeile gingen an
abu dhabi mar später an einen capital
investor das gesamte werftgelände wurde
neu geordnet produktionsbereiche neu
strukturiert allein 4000 tonnen schrott
habe man entsorgt bald genug für ein
kleines containerschiff seit einem
halben jahr seien die dogs wieder voll
zum teil sogar überbucht so der neue
vorstand und auch die reparatur von
handelsschiffen mache hoffnung nicht
zuletzt durch einen code mit dem
weltmarktführer maersk
sie sehen sich eindeutig als retter und
doch können sich nicht alle über den
neustart freuen 300 arbeiter müssen ihn
mit ihrem job bezahlen dass blohm voss
für die großen schiffe ist das ist die
schiffswerft emma flint für die kleinen
denn natürlich müssen auch die barkassen
wie klein fahrgastschiffe und auch die
traditionsschiffe gehegt und gepflegt
werden sei es nur für eine inspektion
eine kontrolle oder auch für kleinere
oder größere reparaturen und jemand der
das mit leidenschaft bei dieser seit
übrigens 8
10 170 existierenden werft im hamburger
hafen ist dies behrens was bringt die
leidenschaft oder wie kommt diese
leidenschaft zustande die sie für die
schiffe entwickeln
in anbetracht der tatsache dass ja nur
noch so wenige werften üblich sind die
leidenschaft kommt aus dem kindesalter
ich bin schon als kleiner putsch immer
um die schiffe gerannt und hat
mitgeholfen die abwechslung in der
kleinen schifffahrt ist ist sehr
vielseitig und ich könnte mir nicht
vorstellen dass es einen ähnlichen job
gibt ähnlich viel spaß jetzt die großen
werften die bauen auch schiffe womit
kommen die reedereien zu ihnen was was
ist wichtig was was ist ihr hauptjob
womit verdient wir sind in erster linie
sind das hauptstandbein ist tatsächlich
reparatur in allen bereichen dass ein
schiff bau maschinenbau innenausbauten
das komplette programm
das heißt wenn bei ihnen jemand anruft
es muss ganz schnell gehen schraube
kaputt das heißt sie können dann auch
schnell reagieren weil das ist bei den
großen letzten jahr ohne frage nicht
erfasst ja das ist unser steckenpferd
die schnelle reaktion dass wir sofort
für die kundschaft da sind und dann auch
die arbeiten schnellstmöglich saniert
wie sehen sie die zukunft so in ihrem
bereich ist das ist das was an das sie
glauben die diese reparaturen weil die
wird ja immer geben eigentlich oder ja
derzeit gehe ich davon aus dass es an
den krisensicherer job ist als werk sind
wir ohnehin sehr vielseitig können auch
in viele
spart mit rein sprechen stahlbau und
rohrleitungsbau wieder kleine die
traditionsschiffe sind ja auch eines der
dinge die sie hegen und pflegen haben
einige ja gesehen bei ihnen auf der
werft mit was tretender die die
liebhaber die oldtimerliebhaber in der
aussprache zu bleiben an sie heran was
muss da gemacht werden das verfallende
an tätigkeiten service services und ja
hilfe bei alten bauteilen tatsächlich
sind auch noch in der lage an alten
motoren zu reparieren und so sind mehr
oder weniger hilferufe zur reparatur der
station
da hängt dann aber auch ein stück
herzblut dran nämlich an oder natürlich
es macht spaß alte technik macht einfach
spaß ist das problematisch nachwuchs zu
finden für für für so ein job in der
werft oder ist es tatsächlich was noch
gut funktionieren durchaus haben wir da
schwierigkeiten nachwuchs bekommen da
sind wir nicht anders strukturiert für
die großen
ja man tut sein bestes wir bilden auch
aus sofern wir kommen aber gut über die
runden
dank herr behrens offensichtlich
überzeugungstäter aller erster güte
thermografen lebt aber eben nicht nur
von den werten wir haben es ja nun
mehrfach auch schon besprochen sondern
natürlich auch vom containerumschlag
aber auch von der kreuzfahrtindustrie
letzten jahrzehnten hat sich ein boom
entwickelt der seinesgleichen sucht aber
die industrie steht auch in der kritik
denn die schiffe fahren nicht
umweltfreundlich genug reaktion von
siewert höchster in hamburg läuft sie
allwöchentlich einen schmucklosen ort im
hafen an
die aida prima für über 3000 passagiere
eines der vorzeige schiffe aus der
schönen immer noch relativ neuen welt
dieser immens wachsenden tourismus
industrie
nicht nur in deutschland aber gerade
auch hier hat das kreuzfahrt wesen
millionen freunde und kunden gefunden
wir wollen jetzt mein schiff erleben
jetzt sind flexibel sehen viele kinder
macht spaß mit über 600
kreuzfahrtschiffen rechnen die deutschen
häfen allein in diesem jahr über drei
milliarden euro setzte die branche
allein hierzulande und weltweit sind in
diesem jahr über 25 millionen menschen
unterwegs und fast verdreifacht hat sich
in den letzten zehn jahren die zahl der
deutschen kreuzfahrer massive kritik vor
allem von umweltverbänden gibt es an den
meist mit schweröl oder diesel laufenden
kraftstoff fressen
gerade die deutschen häfen wie hamburg
suchen allerdings nach lösungen für die
liegezeiten mit umweltfreundlicheren
flüssiggas oder landstrom zwischen 35
und 40 prozent von schiffen die heute an
laufend in hamburg an und land
stromversorgung angeschlossen sind
das ist schon ein guter erfolg das
reicht noch nicht aus das ist auch für
die zukunft eine große herausforderung
auch gerade weil immer mehr preiswerte
kreuzfahrten angeboten werden über die
kosten besonders für die umwelt wird es
wohl noch so manchen streit geben
die kreuzfahrtindustrie boomt das ist
natürlich ein segen für den hamburger
hafen
trotz aller kritik inzwischen ist es
nacht geworden im hamburger hafen das
heißt aber nicht dass hier nichts mehr
passiert im gegenteil die ruhe trügt
gleich wird hier ein großes
kreuzfahrtschiff festmachen über den
bitte festmachen dass eine berufsgruppe
besonders gefragt nämlich die festmacher
des hamburger hafens fram kremser ist
einer von ihnen macht es einen
unterschied es werden ja immer mehr
kreuzfahrtschiffe macht das einen
unterschied kreuzfahrer gegen
beispielsweise container riese oder ist
das schiff ist chef des schiffes schiff
das ist schon cool das ist alles das
gleiche eine stunde auf dem wasser alles
muss festgemacht werden das ist ja sehr
historischer beruf haben
wie kommt das es gibt dem haben sehr
viele berufsgruppen die so traditions-
gelernt sind ist das bei dem fest machen
auch so ähnlich wie beispielsweise bei
den lotsen oder den schlepper kapitän
ja also ursprünglich ist das mal so
gewesen dass es alles familienbetriebe
waren wir dann ihre onkel neffen und
söhne mit reingenommen haben das ist
aber schon lange vorbei jetzt ist
eigentlich mehr ein job für
quereinsteiger so wie ich es auch bin
vor zwölf jahren als gastronom
gescheitert und mit den hafen gern um
geld zu verdienen
seitdem hänge ich hier und
hab mir um meine kumpels mal die familie
mit eingeschworen und mit die fremde die
firma somit aufgebaut
wir gucken wir mal wie es gleich
weitergeht wenn wärme chefs festmacher
regel nummer eins man sollte vor dem
kreuzfahrtschiff am terminal sein
für frank kremser und seine crew geht es
ans terminal altona das eigene schiff
festmachen bevor der junge fahrgast die
flammen neu mein schiff 1 in empfang
genommen werden kann
wie bereiten sie ihre leute jetzt vor
die jungs haben über über funk gehört
welche leihen als erstes genommen wird
die besatzung die da oben auf der
kleinen brücke steht die werden gleich
eine pipeline darüber schmeißen das ist
eine dünne lange die so dick ist wie der
kleine finger und an dieser wurf leine
hängt der große dicke tabu da kommt
jetzt die leine kuba geflogen wo am
anderen ende so genannte affen faust
dran ist und die kann natürlich weh tun
wenn du die mal auf den kopf griff
das ist die spring leine die dafür sorgt
dass das schiff
durch die strömung nicht bewegt wird die
wird jetzt im wasser gelassen von der
besatzung die kollegen hätten am
fahrzeug ziehen jetzt die leine an land
hoch jetzt zum beispiel besteht die
gefahr dass wenn sie die leine
hochziehen dass die leine die jetzt an
der winde ist dass die reist und den
kollegen an der rinde ins gesicht
schlagen kann bzw
wenn die leine wieder ins wasser rauscht
das ist die kollegen hier beim oder
haben wir hier körperteile in der leine
verwickeln und dann ins wasser gezogen
werden
wir kennen das schiff ist jetzt verteilt
oder festgemacht und in ihrer sprache zu
bleiben all den jahren die sie diesen
job machen und sind sie immer noch
fasziniert von der arbeit als festmacher
doch tatsächlich ist es immer noch so
und sie vom ersten tag an mathe job spaß
als sehr abwechslungsreich
die kollegen machen spaß diese privat
viel zusammen ich könnte mir nichts
besseres vorstellen außer vielleicht
fernsehmoderator da bin ich mir nicht so
sicher aber ich nehme ihm das unbenommen
ab dass ihnen das spaß macht und da
spielt die tageszeit auch keine rolle
tagsüber oder nachts die festmacher sind
24 stunden im einsatz in der nacht
passiert auf dem hamburger hafen aber
noch eine ganze menge die produkte die
beispielsweise von den containerschiffen
abgeladen werden die müssen ja noch
weiter verarbeitet werden so zum
beispiel auf dem hamburger großmarkt und
heike rechkemmer hat sich dort für uns
umgesehen
während die einen noch mit der
sicherheitsausrüstung für die großmarkt
führung kämpfen ist gruppenleiter
joachim köhler topfit und dann geht es
auch schon los
doch bevor es ins grüne herz hamburgs
geht erklärt joachim köhler noch die
speziellen großmarkt umgangsformen
wir sind eine große verleger und wie es
üblich ist
in der familie wird sich geduzt
also mein name ist joachim
seit zwei jahren ist er in rente 47
jahre hat sich nachdem die nächte im
großmarkt um die ohren geschlagen
wenn sich einer hier auskennt dann er
[Musik]
ich wurde gefragt ob ich das machen
wollte und weil mein herzblut er merkt
hängt ist es so nach 24 jahren
zugehörigkeit
da habe ich mir gesagt warum nicht
heute händler heimatdorf aus fliegenberg
an der elbe ist sein alter spezi nacht
aktiv und hat auch viel zu erzählen
ich habe auch motor g t gold über das
merkt man einfach später stehen darüber
steht man aber der anpassung und
wochenende nicht so viel auf die piste
machen wir einmal auch nicht ausschlagen
die hochphase des buchs und gemüse
handelns ist eigentlich nachts aber auch
morgens kurz nach sechs ist doch genug
leben wird die besuchergruppe da
der markt lässt ihn nicht los joachim
neu zu höchstform auf ja hier auf merkt
haben wir ungefähr 400 firmen die hier
ansässig sind die wege sind lang 40.000
quadratmeter handelsfläche sind es
allein im erdgeschoss massenweise obst
und gemüse aus der region und aus fünf
kontinenten
was hier natürlich so gelagert wird und
wie das ganze jahr dort das vernichtung
gewaltig also das muss ich natürlich
beeindruckt die vielfalt an waren
wie es dem motto gott eine interessante
geschichte
mittendrin im großmarkt geschäft
anfassen und kaufen für die besucher
zwar nicht erlaubt aber einblicke ins
großmarkt geschäft gibt es für lau
supermärkte kaufen wir nicht mehr auf
einem großmarkt ein und wir müssen uns
von vom supermarkt absetzen dass das ist
unser unser problem wir müssen anders
sein als ich
frische heißt die strategie der blick
hinter die kulissen des großmarktes
zeigt den besuchern seine bedeutung als
handelszentrum
die größe der stände die die menge der
ware und das ist außergewöhnlich und das
ist das was die leute gern sehen wollen
nach zwei stunden ist der kaffee für
nicht nachtaktive lebenselixier pur so
viele eindrücke
das müssen die besucher erst mal
verdauen die grüße man sie produkte
plötzlich anders und ich glaube man geht
künftig auch so ein bisschen anders
einkaufen mit ein bisschen mehr respekt
joachim hätte eigentlich noch viele
geschichten auf lager für mich einige
spät
ich würde gern nicht so wie er das
machen dann ist noch noch lebhafter
vielleicht jetzt nochmal in die federn
das marktgeschehen ist jedenfalls
eingeschlafen
das war sie unsere 24 stunden reportage
von diesem aufregenden ort und ich
verabschiede mich wie man es in hamburg
macht mit einem einfachen tschüss
[Musik]